economía en directo América de Francia
24 Daniel el lunes empezamos una nueva
semana con el premio Nobel de economía
este año que lo comparten tres personas
estas tres personas
que recibieron este galardón por su
extensa investigación sobre los bancos y
sobre las crisis financieras La Academia
explicó que los laureados por medio de
sus investigaciones sentaron las bases
de como el mundo ahora maneja crisis
globales como la de la pandemia del
covid 19 o la gran recesión del 2008
concretamente sobre cómo La regulación
del sector financiero y el apoyo a los
bancos en quiebra pueden evitar una
crisis económica aún más profunda este
galardón sin embargo promete ser
bastante polémico Raúl y es que los
gobiernos de casi todo el mundo
rescataron a los bancos en 2008 y 2009 y
eso generó un torrente de críticas
debido a que los consumidores comunes
sufrieron muchos de ellos perdieron sus
hogares mientras los bancos se salvaban
empezar de ser unos de los principales
culpables de la crisis pero la
investigación de los laureados sugiere
que la sociedad en general se benefició
de estas medidas concretamente Raúl le
resumo todo y es más barato salvar a los
bancos que no salvarlos e irnos a una
recesión como el precio Siempre es así
nosotros pagamos todas las consecuencias
Daniela vamos ahora con él luego en
cifras pues se ha otorgado 54 veces
entre 1969 y 2022 92 individuos han sido
galardonados y en nueve oportunidades
contándola actual se ha entregado a un
trío Solo dos mujeres lo han ganado en
la historia una de ellas es la más joven
en recibir el premio Esther dulce en
2019 cuando tenía 46 años al menos una
mujercita
las mujeres ganen los Nobel no en
general Yo creo que es unos premios muy
masculinizados
sus dimensiones comerciales entre
Estados Unidos y China Raúl la
administración bailan publicó el pasado
viernes un amplio conjunto de controles
de exportación esto incluyó una
exigencia a varias empresas
estadounidenses para que detengan los
envíos de insumos a fábricas de
propiedad totalmente china que produzcan
chips semiconductores Beijing respondió
que lo que busca Washington es frenar
los avances tecnológicos y militares de
Beijing
para mantener la hegemonía tecnológica
Estados Unidos ha hecho un mal uso de
las medidas de control de exportaciones
para bloquear y suprimir maliciosamente
las empresas chinas esta práctica se
desvía del principio de competencia Leal
y viola las normas económicas y
comerciales internacionales no solo
dañará los derechos legítimos de
intereses de las empresas chinas sino
que también afecta los derechos e
intereses de las empresas
estadounidenses
nos vamos hasta México lindo y querido
porque en inflación está impactando al
alimento qué más duele claro México
reporta la inflación más alta de los
últimos 22 años presionada
principalmente por el costo de los
alimentos como en el resto del mundo el
maíz que es un ingrediente esencial de
la comida mexicana ha sido uno de los
que más se ha visto afectado Andrés
cerviño nos cuenta más
los mexicanos sufren las consecuencias
de la inflación el país Azteca cerró el
mes de septiembre con una inflación del
8.70 por ciento la más alta de los
últimos 22 años que afecta directamente
a sus ciudadanos uno de los productos en
los que más se refleja la situación es
en las famosas tortillas para hacer
tacos ya que la producción del maíz es
cada vez más costosa antes podías
comprar tortilla muy fácilmente y ahora
el precio pues subió casi el doble en el
último año entonces creo que eso sí pasa
a afectar a cualquier economía hay
muchos productores que siembran que no
ven reflejadas o ganancia en la
inversión que hacen al producto y
entonces dicen Pues mejor lo vendo no
según el presidente Andrés Manuel López
Obrador y los pronósticos del Gobierno
Federal la inflación llegó a su pico
máximo y los próximos meses irá a la
Baja como sucedió de agosto a septiembre
registrando una reducción del 0.62%
pero mientras tanto los mexicanos luchan
por Buscar su estabilidad económica como
esta mujer que tiene un puesto de
comidas en un mercado de la Ciudad de
México y asegura que su negocio está al
borde del colapso los productos están
también nuestra ganancia no es este
así que porque no podemos nosotros
también subir tanto los precios al
cliente ante la gente no preguntaba por
los precios el gobierno ha anunciado
medidas económicas para hacer frente a
la inflación y a pesar del aumento del
costo de vida la economía de México ha
mejorado durante el 2022 el pronóstico
oficial estima terminar el año con una
tasa de crecimiento del 2.4% y una tasa
de desempleo del 3.5%
y hoy inicia un juicio clave contra
airbus y Air France por un accidente
aéreo que por supuesto todos recordamos
todo lo recordamos Raúl este juicio que
durará nueve semanas está relacionado
con el accidente de un vuelo verás a 330
de Air France que desapareció cuando iba
de Río de Janeiro aparece en junio de
2009 y luego fueron encontrados sus
restos en el Atlántico en la primera vez
que firmas francesas se enfrentan a un
juicio de semejante magnitud tanto del
France como hervás son acusados de
homicidio involuntario por no haber
vigilado los problemas del avión cuyo
mal funcionamiento fue el que provocó el
accidente ambas partes niegan su
responsabilidad pero las familias de las
228 víctimas exigen justicia cifra el
día le va a gustar a usted le gusta el
café Bueno usted sabe más que nadie que
me encanta el café me tomo cuatro tazas
diarias y yo sé que usted no lo odia
Mejor dicho Bueno le tengo una mala
noticia porque comenzar el día con una
taza de café está a punto de convertirse
en un lujo al menos en la Unión Europea
en donde entre agosto del año pasado y
agosto de este año el precio del café ha
subido
16,9%. Pero si ustedes le gusta con
leche este producto hoy es casi una
cuarta parte más caro que hace un año y
si quiere unos kilos de más y le pone
azúcar solamente este ingrediente el
azúcar cuesta hoy 33,4% más Cuál es la
solución no tomar café como Daniela
Bueno no pero yo sí tomaría cafecito
negro a mí no me afectaría tanto el
bolsillo sin azúcar
Dios mío Dani como siempre Gracias por
toda la información más adelante más
economía en una hora